Okay, starting off we've got this work object that's got all of my jobs in it.
Very cool.
Then we come down to the bottom here and we find the locationizer function.
Locationizer's taking in the work_obj from above and
let's take a look inside of it.
We start off by initializing a new array,
which in this case is called locationArray and it starts off empty.
And then we've got a for-in loop.
This for-in loop is going to iterate over every job within work object dot jobs.
So remember, work object is the object that we have up here,
it's being passed in, and we're going to iterate through all of the jobs in it.
For each of the new jobs, we're going to create a variable and
don't worry, it's going to get overwritten every time we run through this loop.
The variable is called new location.
And we're going to set it equal to the location of each job.
So let's break this down a little bit.
We've got the work object, and then within the work object,
we've got the jobs array.
And now because of the for in loop,
we've got the index of each job within the jobs array within the work object.
And then for each job we want the location.
So we're just going to use .notation to get the location.
Once we have each location we're going to push them using the .push
array method.
So we'll start off with the name of the array that we want to return later and
we'll do .push with a location as the parameter.
Once this for loop is finished we're going to return the location array which we
created earlier.
All right, let's go ahead and see if this works.
All right, we'll come down here.
And let's console.log locationizer.
And we'll pass in the work object from above.
And if all goes well, we should see an array of locations where I worked.
We'll hit test run.
Scroll down.
And there we go. The log says that I've worked Mountain View, Seattle.
And I've had two jobs in Nashville.